the New York Post reports the apocalypse
is nigh the end is here by your
emergency food I'm just kidding and say
that it says not a bluff Putin mobilizes
reservist threatens West with nuclear
weapons nuclear weapons
quote when the territorial Integrity of
our country has threatened to protect
Russia and our people we will certainly
use all the means at our disposal it's
not a bluff
Putin accused the west of engaging in
nuclear blackmail and noted statements
of some high-ranking representatives of
the leading NATO States about the
possibility of using nuclear weapons of
mass destruction against Russia he
didn't he did not identify who made such
comments so here's the thing they're
pulling in 300 000 reservists they were
already using these these crazy
incendiary devices all over Ukraine
here's the Big Challenge I don't believe
any of it from anybody you can it can be
the Moscow times it can be Vladimir
Putin himself it can be Joe Biden
himself it could be the New York Times
and I'm gonna be like I don't believe
any of you the US has its interests
they're not going to tell us that right
truth because it would make them look
bad Russia same thing everybody's trying
to propagandize so who knows well the
only thing I can't say is Putin gave
this speech so you can like see him
talking I guess some people think it's a
deep fake but look you know I think
Vladimir Putin absolutely would use
low-yield nuclear weapons on Ukraine to
win this war at the very least he's
gonna say he would you have to as a
president say we will use every every
possible option nothing is off the table
that's a very popular phrase talking
about the end of the world again we saw
and I agree with you Tim a lot of this
is posturing a lot of this is saber
rattling a lot of this is trying to
Galvanize uh you know his country and
his people to go along with what he
believes in we see the United States do
the same thing we can't believe anyone
here but we saw Vladimir Putin kind of
allude to this now he's directly saying
it and he's also doing it in a way which
I think is laying down the groundwork
for a potential strategy which is going
to be dangerous for everyone because the
Ukrainian territories are going to be
going under a specific election to join
Russia very soon which will officially
probably make them Russian territories
now if there's Russian territories that
were former Ukrainian territories when
the ukrainians attacked this Vladimir
Putin is laying down the groundwork
saying specifically I could just nuke
them because they attacked Russian
territory so this is the groundwork that
they're setting up here this is an
extremely dangerous situation and it
could have been all avoided foreign
affairs wrote an article saying
specifically that in April of this year
Russia and Ukraine negotiated a peace
deal they were about to sign a peace
deal they tentatively agreed to it and
then Boris Johnson flew to Ukraine and
said no don't do it this war could have
been stopped it could have been
prevented it wasn't it's only escalating
from here and it's endangering everybody
it may be the end of the world but not
like I don't think Putin's gonna launch
a 50 Megaton bomb ICBM at London or
something no we're talking about small
strategic nuclear weapons but the U.S
would retaliate absolutely otherwise
most likely well it's hard to tell it's
hard to say exactly because we don't
know the full scale we don't know the
latest technology out there when we
think of nuclear weapons we're thinking
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki but we're
thinking incorrectly because this is
technology that is almost 100 years old
and is absolutely nothing compared to
the latest technological advancements
that the Russian military has the
Chinese military has in the US military
has we're talking about weapons that
could end at the planet 10 times over
easily now and that's what we know about
Out imagine what we don't know about so
there's still a lot of mystery here we
don't know what's going on we see one
side of the story being purported a lot
of it is pro-war there should be another
side to it saying hey stop with this
Insanity these politicians shouldn't be
sending people to die for their causes
and their influences this is stupid all
around what is the cause anyway what's
the point War Yeah just they want to
connect the land between Crimea and
Russia they want that eastern Ukraine
it's far more complicated and a lot of
it is energy also included but but
that's just I'll keep it simple for the
sake of contemporary politics Russia has
one warm water Port Crimea if Ukraine
goes NATO they lose access to the Black
Sea and shipping oil and other resources
they can get there from the East I was
looking at a map but it's a bridge and I
haven't one Bridge into your territory
is not secure so they want they want
multiple highways there's two big
highways that go in through Ukraine that
they probably want access to they need
access to the Black Sea they have a
fleet there they need it and then
they're going to be holding the turkey
you understand turkey has the Bosphorus
yeah straight As Turkish so if the
Russians turkey and Greece is part of
NATO at odds with each other and there's
also a big flash point there that may
lead to a war between uh Greece and
Turkey and there's also a lot of oil and
energy found specifically in that region
that Russia is now occupying that could
make Ukraine a Petro state if Ukraine is
a Petro State and is with the European
Union it's game over for Russia and they
know this all right it's all it's all
extremely esoteric let's wait let's
bring it back home to Earth you guys are
rock stars so you know the the when are
you guys playing in Moscow
you know this stuff's like this is
really in the weed stuff but I'm
wondering if it's this kind of thing is
breaching into your world concerns about
global recessions economic collapse war
Civil War or whatever oh it it all
affects us I feel like musicians are the
ones that get affected by everything
right it's right away we noticed um a
recession is right now A lot of people
are still trying to figure out you know
I guess a fish actually because no one
will admit it but we're in a recession
we can tell when we're on the road right
when you're when gas prices are six
hours a gallon when hotels have doubled
in cost like people don't want to travel
anymore you get less people con you know
going to concerts we're here on stage
and the panties being thrown at you are
from Walmart yeah right right instead of
Victoria's Secret they don't come
because they'll tell you about it we
were going to throw our paintings on
stage but we just couldn't yeah we met
people on the last couple runs we've
done that have three jobs and and can't
afford the rent so it's it's a very
weird time and and to to see us
constantly throwing as much money as we
are at War right you know how many
billions are we given towards this world
on the books yeah right and and there's
more coming and we did this already once
in Afghanistan we've already we've
already you know given so much money
towards War right our biggest fear for
the last couple years was oh we don't
want to go to war we don't go to war
well here we are we're right into a war
right now we're feeding money into this
war while people here in the United
United States can't pay the rent there's
uh places don't have clean water in the
U.S there's there's all this stuff going
on here but but we continue to ignore
that and and focus on this war like it's
like it's a good thing now now I hear
you know the Arts are overrun with like
leftists and liberals y'all didn't vote
for Biden did you we did not you know
and and at the end of the day
um
I feel like I I knew what was going to
happen that's happening right now I felt
like that came with with that vote in
you know I feel like when when yeah I
feel like when if we were to vote for
Biden it would be to
vote for what we're talking about like
almost a recession you know an increase
in energy we knew when he came in the
gas was going to go to six dollars a
gallon we knew hotels were going to
double we knew so so for us you know
we're seeing our whole lives change and
then not not to to Discount the fact
that in 2020 we were the industry that
they pretty much told your shutdown
you're not playing any concerts you know
the the only article we ever got written
in Rolling Stone about us was that you
know we had number one hits we sold
hundreds of thousands of Records Rolling
Stone ignored us our entire career we
played one outdoor Festival in late 2020
and they called us murders they were
like adelita's ways currently killing
people as they play a concert outside
it's like you know to
to use the media to try to do that to a
band that's been working for 15 years to
write the first story about us to be a
negative one about how we wanted to give
people entertainment during a really
tough time which we continue to do right
we we went on tour with Skillet we were
doing live streams for our fans playing
live concerts for them when everyone was
locked in their houses like we care
about our fans and and we wake up
thinking every day you know how can we
how can we make them you know feel like
they're with us now how can we make them
feel like we're thinking of them so we
put on these live streams we played
these concerts and we got crucified in
in the record industry
creepy but if you if you come out and
you put on your pink little hat we have
a Ukrainian flag and and Advocate and
vote towards giving billions of dollars
to the war effort you're good they put
you on front State they put you as as
the main act with all these big
celebrities this big Ukraine benefit and
they'd be like you're so brave and and
Noble doing this it seems like that a
lot of people in Industry just in
general are obsessed with germ theory of
disease and they don't focus enough on
terrain they theory of disease these
yeah and when they're wrong they don't
ever come out and say anything about the
wrong information they were given right
that that's the problem that I had the
problem that I have is if you're going
to force someone into a way and then and
then you're not right about that way
after facts come in you you should say
sorry sorry about that guys or or like
you know don't try to rule with such an
iron fist over people the way that these
paths these past couple years I've been
iron fisty you know you guys played in
late 2020 you probably you played
throughout 2021 I'd imagine you know
you're playing now how how would you how
would you uh like describe your fans do
they tend to be people who are like this
is this is busted this is this is BS
you're doing a good thing or do you get
people who are wearing masks being like
why aren't you wearing a mask well we've
had it both ways we've had we've had
people stop following us because that
type of thing going on but we've also
had people come around and say look you
know
um I felt this way but then after
learning and doing my own research and
learning more about this you know I was
kind of mad at you guys at this point
but now that I'm here and I've learned
more you know I understand because what
we're trying to do is provide
entertainment for for our fans and also
feed our family not become one of the
stories that we're hearing so many of
right now like people are getting
evicted from their homes people are
living in tents we travel all across the
world and we travel all across the
United States and when you're in some of
these Progressive States
um I can name a list of them you're
you're people will not believe you're
playing out you see the agenda playing
out you see thousands of tents thousands
of homeless people thousands of people
waiting for just a truck to come by to
give them water you know when we played
Portland over the winter
there were there were thousands of tents
in the streets and there were ambulances
coming and picking up people who had
frozen to death the night before
Portland in Portland it's not even that
cold right but they're older people
right you you if you're cold and you're
older and you don't got the means to to
survive right your immune systems are
lower people were dying and they'll just
come pick them up in the ambulance drive
them off and you don't hear anything
about this and we we I think what helps
us have the the head on us that we have
is we meet so many of our fans we hear
so many of these stories we hear stories
about people working three jobs getting
evicted we hear stories about people
working 50-hour weeks and they can't
afford uh anything extra right like we
have fans that that have been the 20 30
shows of ours that write us emails like
I'm so sorry that I'm not going to make
it when you come to Houston because I
can't afford to drive the normal three
hours like I would gas is seven dollars
six dollars a gallon rent is this you
know it's it's really affecting the
music industry and for some reason our
peers in the music industry we continue
to support this type of of uh you know
attack on gas that's our our careers
there's no there's no electric vehicle
that we could drive across the country
right now in Turin right yeah it doesn't
exist technology is not there yet do
people ever wear masks when they perform
hold on did you guys see what band was
it uh what band was it the Clean Hands
guys oh yeah yeah oh yeah who was that
yeah you see this one they were like
everybody has Clean Hands and they're
all like yeah yeah it's called dude no
oh I know these I know the name you know
the name it's the uh I predict a riot
you know that band yeah
look what they're saying about well yeah
we got to exiled man they found out we
love Liberties
that hood was everybody wash your hands
they were like
being in a band does it feel like a cult
like you're the cult leaders and it's a
cult like the fans now I have your
Kaiser Chiefs maybe I don't know about
these guys like I wonder about the fan
artist relationship because I'm an
artist too and I'm real concerned like I
don't want to you know I want people to
think for themselves and to be
independent but I also want people to
come watch me perform when I perform we
know like half of our fans by name and
we have a lot of them and we and and he
takes the time to meet as many fans
after every single show and we we
connect with our fans and we make that's
our number one priority is connection
with our fans yeah because that's the
only reason we're where we are today as
an independent band because everybody in
the corporate music Industries try to
crush us since we became independent so
we we have to be with our fans thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership ship helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there